before Friday January 11th do you think
Bryce Harper will make a decision to
come to your Los Angeles Dodgers I
wouldn't be sad about it I've got my
Dodger socks on I think you know that's
just a coincidence but it's a very odd
coincidence most of my clothing is
either black or Dodger blue so you know
I think it would be great if he came
that I also think we can do without him
I mean the team is built two homegrown
players I mean we had a lot of people
like months the example last year cuz
sort of come out of nowhere so it's not
a necessity but it would be awesome to
see him play in las but don't you think
the trade of Puig right and and Kemp the
paint all day pretty bleak precursor
though I mean I looked at my little
piggy bank yesterday and got a little
sad that he's gone now but your what
what is it I think that gave away last
year the Puig II bank that they gave out
there sitting on my desk yeah you should
have one of those by the way we should
have a piggy bank you should it's not
officially dated I know yeah it's a
piece of history now yeah artifact but I
think their philosophy might just be to
clear up that money there may not be any
big signing coming with the way this
office works so you know it's it's sort
of hard to tell
clearing money for who I mean luxury tax
in for next year right I mean they just
are thinking ahead there's a you know
free agent market next year to think
about I guess so yeah and so are you are
you locked in to the Laker season best
you can right now yeah I had a really
great time watching the Christmas Day
game with my whole family watching the
everybody do it without LeBron over the
Warriors that was pretty exciting right
so I know and you know obviously he I
bet she's coming back this week they
haven't made an announcement yet yeah
you know I think he's gonna return yeah
that was I guess that day was also mixed
in with terror that something horrible
had happened right here for him I know
yeah you don't want to see that so I
mean what's it like to have a team where
Bryce Harper might be coming and then
your basketball team gets LeBron James I
mean that's some water ski you want some
yacht you're waterskiing right yeah we
are spoiled in the city to see that sort
of thing and it's you know the the word
is that Bryce really wants to come play
here and who can blame them I mean it's
right it's a great city to play in so
now we've had this conversation before
but for the
so you're from Los Angeles would you say
you're from Los Angeles born here but my
parents are both from Birmingham Alabama
and shockingly don't have any strong
feelings either way towards Alabama or
Auburn how is that possible
and neither of them went to either
school siblings didn't really go to
either school but you have to declare if
you live in that state well my dad
studied theatre in college so he liked
football he's actually a lifelong
Falcons fan he was the rare case in the
south of actually preferring the NFL I
think to the SEC right but yeah I mean
his best friend went to Auburn but
there's just was never a strong pole
either way but so was it particularly
big in in your folks household that your
first film role you played the son of
one of the best players in the history
of Alabama Forrest that is true that is
part of the the family history now yeah
that was a pretty big deal yeah you're
in you're in the household look yeah the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience